i'm paul north
i teach in the german department at yale
this
is a series at the whitney humanities
center called the value of marx's
capital these are the frankie lectures
and the humanities
at the whitney humanities center i need
to do some
thank yous first of all the frankie
lectures are made possible by the
generosity of richard and barbara
frankie
and are intended to present important
topics in the humanities
to a wide and general audience i'd like
to thank alice kaplan the director of
the whitney humanities center for making
possible what
seemed to have been potentially
impossible this year so thank you alice
to sandra mullan bowles and lyanna
hirschfeld crowen
for doing the organization and to audrey
leake
our intrepid brilliant undergraduate
tech assistant thank you
the workshop is going to run like this
we'll have a presentation from our
speaker and then we'll do questions
i'm going to ask you to hold your
questions if you can until
after the speaker speaks and then to put
them in the chat
will then go through the chat and open
up your mics when it's time for you to
read your question if you
put in questions earlier they're likely
to get lost
i like to start with a quote from a text
from the speaker so i want to start from
a with a quote from our speaker from the
boston review
in february of 2018 quote asking what
the slave trade
says about marx requires that we start
where marx did
with analysis of the commodity form but
we need to replace the bolt of linen
marks used
as the iconic object of that analysis
not with slave cultivated cotton that
was more central to 19th century
industrial manufacturing or even the
slave grown sugar
that fueled the colonial wealth marks
erroneously identified as part of
capitals
capitalism's pre-history to heed
johnson's call
to quote use the history of slaves as
the source rather than the subject of
knowledge unquote we will have to
instead put the enslaved human herself
at the center of our analysis of the
commodity form
when i read the sentence i was really
galvanized and
invited stephanie smallwood to join us
we're really
grateful that you're here stephanie
smallwood is associate professor of
history and comparative
history of ideas at the university of
washington seattle
where she's also a faculty associate of
the harry bridges center for labor
studies
her research and teaching explore early
modern histories of slavery colonialism
and race
with particular emphasis on the
transatlantic slave trade racial
capitalism
and african diasporas in the americas as
far as i can see she's the
most interesting political economist
of slavery going she's the author of
saltwater slavery
a middle passage from africa to american
diaspora from 2007 which won
the 2008 frederick douglass prize from
yale's
own gilder airman center she's at work
on a project called africa in the
atlantic world the geopolitical history
and we're really happy to have you and
welcome
thank you so much um it's an honor to be
here
an honor to spend the evening discussing
the value of capital um and i'll just
say that i
am relieved not quite
fully relieved but happy to be starting
this conversation knowing that
um that thing that we're all watching
obsessively
has started to inch in the right
direction
so i can kind of leave my obsession with
the election and and focus on what we're
here for today
um thank you paul for that uh quote
it is a perfect segue i think into what
i want to do today
i want to start by saying a little bit
about
how i've come to develop a deep interest
in the marxian account of capital
um it's not an obvious set of interests
for me since i'm actually
not a specialist in political theory or
political economy but as a historian of
slavery
and of the transatlantic slave trade
and one whose research has focused
particularly
on how the early modern atlantic system
organized itself around the production
and circulation
of people as commodities i guess it
became inevitable
that eventually i would have to engage
with marx
so off and on over the years since i
published
saltwater slavery i've dabbled in the
debates
on the relationship of capitalism to
slavery
and i've done so always a bit confused
and bemused by the ways those debates
rarely extend beyond questions
about 19th century antebellum
slavery in the us
the question that follows me around
relentlessly whenever i'm deep
into marx's uvra concerns the
relationship of capitalism
to the transatlantic world of slavery in
the 16th 17th
and 18th centuries so my questions have
less to do
with the entanglements of british
abolitionism
cotton slavery in the u.s south and the
rise of industrial capitalism in the
19th century
and more to do with how to make sense
of the long history of what marx called
the capitalist era beginning in the 16th
century
so with the thoughts i'm going to share
this afternoon or this evening for you
all i want to problematize
a central assertion of marx's account of
capital and that's namely his insistence
that the circumstances in which money
could be transformed into capital were
limited
to the time and place of 19th century
industrialization
in northern europe and i want to suggest
that the histories of transatlantic
circulation
and enslavement of african people must
be at the center
of any adequate account of capitalism
and in doing so i'm going to propose
that we need to rethink
the marxian account of new world slavery
as
capital so-called primitive accumulation
a useful place to begin i think is to
remind ourselves
why marx insisted on framing the
conditions of possibility
for the capital relation to emerge as
narrowly as he did
and on that point i want us to remember
that the revolution
he was trying to eliminate was not the
production of surplus value itself right
that's not what was special
about capitalism more precisely
it was the money owner's discovery
that he can generate surplus value in
perpetuity
by the appropriation of a particular
form of labor
which of course as we know from our
reading of capital
was the specific form of free labor
so i'm going to go ahead and share my
screen and pull up
the first slide
marks elaborated the conditions that
made
labor free very precisely
what the capital relation required
according to him
was labor power's presence in the market
as a commodity and we can use this
passage from his discussion
of the sale and purchase of labor power
one of several very explicit statements
on this
to recall marx's precise words regarding
the four conditions
that labor's appearance in the market as
a commodity
required number one
it had to be sold as a commodity by
its possessor and so we get marx telling
us that labor power
can appear on the market as a commodity
only if
and in so far as its possessor the
individual whose labor power it is
offers it for sale or sells it as a
commodity
second he tells us that the possessor of
labor power has to have
full ownership of his labor power he
must possess himself
and so marx writes the possessor must
have it at his disposal he must be the
free proprietor
of his own labor capacity hints
of his person third
the two parties to this transaction the
owner of money
and the owner of labor power must be
equals
juridically at least and so bar marx
insists that both have to be
equal in the eyes of the law
and lastly the system's
infinite momentum right that essential
feature
that is capital's ability to reproduce
valorization in perpetuity requires that
the possessor of labor power
be compelled to return to the market
over and over again
and so it is necessary that he sell his
labor power
only for a delimited period of time and
on this
mark's rights for this relation to
continue
the proprietor of labor power must
always
sell it for a limited period only
why because if he were to sell the
totality of his labor power
all at once he would effectively make
himself
into an enslaved person and so marx
concludes this passage saying for if he
were to sell it
in a lump once and for all he would be
selling himself
converting himself from a free man into
a slave
from an owner of a commodity into
a commodity
and so with this we have marx's central
axiom
that capital's endless self valorization
requires not just the labor power
that labor power itself become a
commodity
but more precisely that it appear
repeatedly in the market
and further that this can only occur
when labor power is brought to the
market
by the free person in whom it is
embedded
what he referred to as alienation
by sale so the african enslaved worker
does not
and indeed cannot appear as a central
protagonist
and marks his account of capital for
marx
if the laborer in question is enslaved a
fully commoditized person
we can no longer be in the terrain of
the capital relation
if the circulation of labor power freely
alienated by
sale is the necessary condition of
possibility
for the emergence of the capital
relation
what i want to ask is the place of
atlantic slavery
and its circulation of labor power
alienated by coercion
and capital story as someone who studies
the commoditization
of people the full commoditization of
people
and the circulation of commoditized
people for their labor
this is what i want to keep open as a
question
i want to ask whether slavery as
capitalism is as unthinkable
as marx insisted and what i'll try to do
today
is persuade you that enslaved africans
can
and should be at the center of our
account
of modern capital
so i'm going to organize my thoughts for
this evening
around two questions number one what did
marx think
he knew about slavery and number two
what did marx need to know about slavery
but fail to
ask so the first question
what did marx think he knew
about slavery
so much
okay so what did marx think
he knew about slavery well before he had
begun the research at the british museum
that would become
capital marx had already identified
slavery
as an important part of the story of
19th century industrialization
in his 1847 poverty of philosophy
he famously wrote that direct slavery
is just as much the pivot of bourgeois
industry as
machinery credits etc without slavery
you have no cotton without cotton you
have no modern industry
it is slavery that has given the
colonies their value
it is the colonies that have created
world trade
and it is world trade that is the
precondition
of large-scale industry thus
he writes slavery is an economic
category of the greatest
importance marx knew
the value slavery gave to the new world
colonies because he was reading
the current historical literature on
english colonizing
works by hermann maryvale for example
that explained which colonies were
producing commodities for the
international market
and which ones weren't and told him of
jamaica's status for instance as the
greatest sugar growing country in the
world
that is to say marx knew the aggregate
measure of the wealth returned to europe
by the importation and consumption of
colonial commodities
and it was in this idiom that he
understood the value
slavery gave to the colonies
and it's in this sense also that marx
assigned to new world
slavery the role of contributing
substantially to capital's era
of primitive accumulation the amassing
of capital and labor power
that had taken place outside the
cyclical movement of capital
the historical break we might say or
shift
that as marx put it was quote not the
result
of the capitalist mode of production but
rather its point of departure
what marx characterized as the treasures
captured
outside europe by undisguised looting
enslavement and murder that flowed back
to the mother country
and were turned into capital there
next slide please
and so in this sharply worded
and often quoted statement we get
marx's most explicit observation
regarding
the multiple and global appropriations
he's characterized as capital's
pre-history
of primitive accumulation he writes that
the discovery of gold and silver in
america
the extirpation enslavement and
entombment
and minds of the indigenous population
of that continent
the beginnings of the conquest and
plunder of india
and the conversion of africa into a
preserve
for the commercial hunting of black
skins
are all things which characterize the
dawn
of the era of capitalist production
these idyllic proceedings he says
ironically
are the chief moments of primitive
accumulation
but if it wasn't as an economic category
that the particular historical instance
of new world
slavery was an important part of capital
story
what i want to ask about slavery
as a category of labor we should notice
in this passage that marx has invoked
european slave trading in africa the
commercial hunting of black skins
but he has not explicitly named the new
world plantation
and its expropriation of african labor
instead here it is the mineral wealth
and the expropriation of indigenous
labor that occupies
his interest in slavery as a mode of
production
in the colonized americas
for a 19th century european political
economy general
generally speaking slavery was a static
and unchanging mode of production and as
such
it was understood to have certain
universal characteristics
as a system of labor exploitation
slavery was understood to claim the
spoils of surplus labor
the same as any system that concentrated
ownership of the means of production
in the hands of a dominant social class
but and this is significant conventional
wisdom had
it that slavery would not turn surplus
labor
into surplus value or profit
because slave labor power was part of
the means of production
it would not be subjected to the scale
of exploitation
and abuse associated with the drive to
profit
from labor surplus the expectation then
was that
owners would not be inclined to direct
slave labor power toward production for
market exchange
and so slavery was expected to limit
itself
to the production of use values but not
approach the production of exchange
values
next slide please
marx explained it this way he wrote it
is clear
that in any economic formation of
society
where the use value rather than the
exchange value
of the product predominates surplus
labor
will be restricted by a more or less
confined set of needs
and that no boundless thirst for surplus
labor will arise from the character of
production
itself hence in antiquity
overwork becomes frightful only when the
aim
is to obtain exchange value in its
independent monetary shape
i.e in the production of gold and silver
the recognized form of overwork here
is forced labor until death nevertheless
these are exceptions in antiquity
so there were exceptions specifically in
the context of the production of mineral
wealth
but the normative rule so it was thought
was that slavery used labor power
without despoiling it and in this
crucial sense it did not approach
the abuses typical of 19th century
industrial wage
labor for instance when describing how
the value of labor power
is determined by the social costs of its
production
marx drew on the example of ancient
roman slavery to illustrate the point
explaining that the overseers in ancient
rome received less food than the
agricultural slaves they supervised
because they expended less labor
than the enslaved workers
and so in this sense 19th century
european political economy
understood slavery as a patriarchal
and benign mode of production that was
inimical
to the features unique to capital its
drive
as marx called it to produce exchange
value
and the economies of scale by which its
circuits of valorization
renewed themselves in limitless fashion
as he put it this at least
was the body of theoretical assumptions
marx inherited
in 19th century economic thought
so what did marx need to know about
slavery but failed to ask
it was by exceeding the limits it was
supposed to have
that slavery became an economic category
so important to capital's story
the system of slavery made by european
interventions in africa and the americas
was a novel and unprecedented one and it
shared with european industrial wage
labor
elements marx revealed as central
to the workings of capital it produced
surplus value
by making labor power available in the
market and virtually virtually
limitless form and it did so
by the bureaucratic management of market
circulations
marx needed to devote sustained
analytical attention to the
bureaucratically managed market
circulations
that roped africa into europe's
transatlantic commercial network
and pulled enslaved african labor power
into the net of european colonizing in
the americas
and he needed to reconcile his inherited
abstractions about slavery as a mode of
production
with the actual material history of
slavery in the new world
to do that he needed to ask how exactly
did slavery give the colonies their
value
he needed to ask more precisely how did
the labor power of enslaved africans
give the colonies so much value
a full account of modern capitalism
needs to be able to explain slavery's
transformation
under european colonization in the
americas
but these questions were already
foreclosed
by marx's a historical understandings of
slavery
and the limited scale of his imagination
with regard to the conditions of
possibility
for the capital relation to emerge
the result was the awkward and erroneous
grafting of an anachronistic theory of
slavery
onto an historical reality whose full
scope
and operative logics marx failed to
fully
grasp next slide please
so we get statements like this one that
produced the provocative
and often quoted pedestal metaphor by
making american slavery the benign
system that 19th century economic
thought imagined all slavery systems to
be
until transformed by 19th century
industrialization
only then when the cotton industry
emerged
was american slavery so it was thought
transformed
into something akin to the capital
relation itself
and so marx writes while the cotton
industry
introduced child slavery into england
and the united states
it gave the impulse for the
transformation of the earlier
more or less patriarchal slavery
into a system of commercial exploitation
in fact the veiled slavery of the wage
laborers in europe needed the
unqualified slavery of
the new world as its pedestal
next slide please
and we get this passage that continues
the line of discussion we looked at a
few minutes ago
regarding slavery's general orientation
toward production of use values with no
boundless thirst for surplus labor
according to 19th century economic
theory
marx continues the thought as follows
as soon as peoples whose production
still moves within the lower forms of
slave labor
the corvae etc are drawn into a world
market dominated by the capitalist mode
of production
whereby the sale of their products for
export develops
into their principal interest the
civilized horrors of overwork
are grafted onto the barbaric horrors of
slavery
serfdom etc hence
the negro labor and the southern states
of the american union
preserved a moderately patriarchal
character
as long as production was chiefly
directed
to the satisfaction of immediate local
requirements
but in proportion as the export of
cotton became a vital interest to those
states
the overworking of the negro and
sometimes the consumption of his life
and seven years of labor became a factor
and a calculated and calculating system
it was no longer a question of obtaining
from him a certain quantity of useful
products
but rather of the production of surplus
value
itself
so marx recognized an affinity
between capitalism and slavery the one
was the pedestal for the other
but his only recourse to explain the
relationship was the egregiously
erroneous notion
that there was nothing interesting to
know or observe
about the american slave labor system
until
it came under the dark cloud of european
demand for slave grown cotton
only then did it become in his view
a calculated and calculating system
we have to wonder as he conducted the
research that became capital
sitting in the famed reading room of the
british museum
a monument to british colonialism
founded by
18th century naturalist and plantation
physician han sloan
did marx imagine that enslaved people
ate better
than their overseers across nearly two
centuries producing tobacco
and rice and indigo and the plantation
societies of english north america
the same as they purportedly did and
what he understood as the benign
slave system of ancient rome
next slide please
there's one crucial passage in capital
where marx comes closest
to getting it right and it is this very
long passage
where drawing on contemporary economist
j.e karen's book the slave power
marx comes closest to a full elaboration
of slavery's transformation under racial
capitalism and colonialism
the slave owner buys his worker he
writes in the same way as he buys his
horse
if he loses his slave he loses a piece
of capital
which he must replace by fresh
expenditure on the slave market
but take note of this and now he is
quoting cairns
the rice grounds of georgia or the
swamps of the mississippi
may be fatally injurious to the human
constitution
but the waste of human life which the
cultivation of these
districts necessitates is not so great
that it cannot be repaired from the
teeming preserves of virginia and
kentucky
considerations of economy moreover which
under a natural system
afford some security for humane
treatment
by identifying in the master's interest
with the slaves preservation
when once trading in slaves is practiced
becomes reasons for racking to the
uttermost
the toil of the slave for when his place
can be
at once supplied from foreign preserves
the duration of his life becomes a
matter of less moment
than its productiveness while it lasts
next slide
it is accordingly a maxim of slave
management and slave importing countries
that the most effective economy is that
which takes
out of human channel in the shortest
space of time
the utmost amount of exertion it is
capable of putting forth
it is in the tropical culture where
annual profits
often equal the whole capital of
plantations that negro life
is most recklessly sacrificed it is the
agriculture of the west indies which has
been for
centuries prolific a fabulous
wealth that has engulfed millions of the
african race
it is in cuba at this day whose revenues
are reckoned by
millions and whose planters are princes
that we see in the servile class the
coarsest
fair the most exhausting and unremitting
toil
and even the absolute destruction of a
portion of its numbers
every year and now marx quotes
the roman poet horus the name is changed
but the tale
is told of you and concludes
for the slave trade read or substitute
labor market for kentucky and virginia
substitute ireland and the agricultural
districts of england scotland and wales
for africa substitute germany
what's missing here though it's right
there beneath
marx's eyes is theorization
of the slave trade itself as a labor
market
it is not just analogous to the european
labor market but
rather the original instantiation of a
particular
kind of labor market one that produced
and circulated
commodified labor power in the pursuit
of surplus
value and did so on a limitless scale
marx's invocation of a historical
process that drew slavery
into a world market should
have been a reference to the
transatlantic slave trade
and the system of plantation slavery it
sustained
across the colonized americas
but it wasn't his account of new world
slavery is
organized around production of use
values
and thus preserving a moderately
patriarchal character as he put it
until it was transformed by the
distorting
influence of capital in the 19th century
is
more than a harmless anachronism
in other words he doesn't just get the
chronology wrong
he's unable to fully perceive the nature
of the relationship
of slavery to capitalism he credited
new world slavery with being an
important economic
category but absent theorization of
slavery's transformation
under european colonialism he failed to
perceive
the new labor form it innovated
so marx ended up stuck without a
theoretical foundation
for organizing what he knew to be true
of new world slavery that it was
organized
to produce surplus value and did so
on an economy of scale never before seen
in world history this made it not just
an
important economic category but moreover
a mode of production that begged for
theorization
on the same terms as those he deployed
to
understand wage labor and to elaborate
the formula
for capital's production of surplus
value
for lack of an ability to theorize this
transformation of slavery under european
colonizing in the americas
marx cannot but misapprehend
what was its most important feature
with regard to the formula for capital
by erasing the long history of colonial
chattel slavery
and the transatlantic slave trade that
fueled it
marx failed to account for its economy
of scale
and how it achieved that scale
by the ongoing appearance of african
commodified labor power
in the marketplace the african captive
purchased by representatives of the
european state
on the african coast and sold to
european
planter settlers in the plantation
colonies in the americas
was the primordial figure of the worker
whose labor power was subjected
to the violences of capital's boundless
thirst
and voracious appetite for surplus labor
by the terms then of his own
theorization of capital
american slavery was organized around an
iteration of the capital relation from
its beginnings
next slide please
marx could not empirically know
free labor to be the singular
labor form able to sustain the capital
relations
social reproduction and satisfy its
hunger
for self-polarization because he did not
closely examine what preceded
that innovation labor powers
continual replacement in the market
by the always reliable reappearance
on the atlantic horizon of the
transatlantic slave ship
colonial slavery represents a
transformation
antecedent too and no less revolutionary
than the industrial systems
appropriation of free wage labor
we might call this system colonial slave
capitalism its circulations began
with money expended in europe to buy
commodities to exchange for people
on the african coast and value was
mediated
by a transatlantic series of commodity
conversions
european commodities exchanged for
captive people
on the african coast people converted to
commodified labor power and the
transatlantic slave ships commodified
labor power
consumed in the cultivation of cash
crops
in the american plantation systems and
finally
the circulation closed with money's
final return
back to its initial point of departure
in valorized form
by the sale of the sugar or tobacco
or rice or indigo made by the alienation
of slave labor power by coercion
with all that that entailed of violence
and indifference toward the life
of the enslaved worker
the economic form created by the
circulation of african people as
commodities
was money and moreover capital
and the marxian sense of being money
whose value
was enlarged by the expropriation of
their labor power
in other words the transatlantic
circulation
of africans followed capital's general
formula it put money into circulation to
produce surplus value that in turn
produced
more money there is no more
straightforward expression
of what marx called quote the
valorization of value
than what a jamaican planter named
carrie helyar
said of the enslaved africans he
purchased with
money advanced by his brother in england
after acquiring 14 enslaved africans out
of a dutch ship
in 1642 he wrote to his brother
promising that by their labor
and the prophets that would ensue he
would quote
make these negroes buy
more
the 18th century british promoter of
slavery
malachi apostlethwaite opined
that the africa trade was an
inexhaustible fund of wealth for the
state
but it was more than that the system it
fueled
was the original laboratory in which the
owners of money
first realized and innovated
the production of surplus value by labor
power's
ongoing alienation in the marketplace
that's what
carrie heller understood and it's what
marx evaded
in his account of capital
so moving now toward a close what i've
tried to show here today
is that the colonial atlantic slave
system
was a self-perpetuating one a system of
surplus value production
driven by commoditization of labor power
in the marketplace it innovated
this by what i'm calling the alienation
of labor
by coercion and did so prior to the
european innovation of what marx called
the alienation of labor power by sale
my point is not to flatten or dissolve
the distinction between these two forms
what i am insisting on though is that
characterizing the colonial slave system
as one his principal role was as an
aggregate accumulation of wealth that
was primitive
in the sense of being outside of and
external to capitalism's time and place
in 19th century northern europe marx's
primitive accumulation
obscures more than it reveals
by attributing to colonial slavery only
the aggregate accumulation of startup
capital
the primitive accumulation concept masks
and leaves uninvestigated and
untheorized
the ways colonial slavery produced that
wealth
by an innovation in the expropriation of
labor power
it erases colonial slavery scale
it distorts its chronology and it
includes the bureaucratic
rationalization of expropriation by
violence
developed across three centuries
prior to american slavery's turn to
cotton production
to invoke lisa lowe's analysis of what
she calls
the intimacies of for continents a
formulation that is so helpful
for seeing relations otherwise obscured
by liberal economic
and political thought it obscures the
ways the managed
violences of colonial capitalist slavery
across three centuries were not external
to europe at all
how much enslaved or indentured
labor power for instance did marx
himself consume
and the sugar that sweetened the tea he
surely drank
as he sat in the british museum reading
room
developing his critique of political
economy
as lisa lowe explains by way of a
brilliant reading
of the novel vanity fair thackeray's
distillation of early victorian british
society revealed
what marx's account of capital did not
the intimacies and i'm quoting here
between colonial commodities
in early victorian households and the
imperial
relations to africa asia and the
americas
to which they were inextricably tied end
quote
marx's account according to lowe
simultaneously recognized
and ingeniously suppressed the histories
and geographies of production that
brought sugar
tea silks and so forth to british
consumers
and so if a central event of primitive
accumulation
and its hastening of the shift from
feudalism to capitalism
was the transformation of the slave mode
of production
such that it could exceed the limits
that traditionally inherit
in the use of slave labor power
it changes our understanding of the
relationship
between the two in important and
profound ways
it suggests that by understanding
american slavery as the pedestal
on which european wage slavery stood if
we want to keep
marx's pedestal and veil metaphor
we are not just naming slave grown
cotton
as the fuel that fed the system of wage
slavery in europe
but moreover we're naming as primordial
the three centuries of bureaucratically
managed production of surplus value
through expropriation of labor power in
the americas
we are thus producing better
understanding
of why slavery and capitalism share so
many features
why slave labor and wage labor are not
as distinct
as liberal economic theory would have us
believe we are unmasking the otherwise
occluded
transformation of the slave mode of
production
under european colonialism
and we're better understanding the
nature of the pedestal
of colonial slavery
both colonial slavery and 19th century
industrial production achieved economies
of scale
and limitless capacity from money's
perpetual self valorization
by the managed bureaucracy of labor's
alienation in the market
we must not collapse the distinction
between the alienation of labor
by coercion and its alienation by sale
but insofar as the one preceded the
other
and represents a primordial innovation
realized by slavery's transformation
under colonialism
we can usefully rethink the way we
periodize
and organize our understanding of
capital's
long chronology it's in this sense
that i insist that colonial slavery must
be understood
as more central even than marx
recognized with his provocative
metaphors
that name the proximity of slavery to
capitalism
without adequately grasping the nature
of that relationship
and in this sense to remind us
of the genealogy of black radical
thinkers including w
e b du bois clr james and eric williams
who've made the same point in various
ways
i'm especially indebted to the
sociologist oliver cox
who suggested in his 1964 work
capitalism as a system that quote
marx begins his analysis of the nature
of capitalism
almost where he might have ended it
and as is commonly the case in classical
economics
he relegates as subsidiary the very
things which should have been the center
of his study
his primitive accumulation is none other
than fundamentally
capitalist accumulation end quote
across three centuries capital realized
the means to satisfy its hunger
for valorization by the consumption of
some 12 and a half
million souls well before it shifted to
the scene
elaborated so painstakingly by marks
the labor market where the wage worker
appears
under the ruse that is bourgeois freedom
but is in fact
the end line of his own enslavement
if we can understand capitals alienation
of the wage workers ostensibly free
labor power
as further innovation of the preceding
three centuries of alienation by direct
coercion
as much as being a revolutionary break
with that past
we have the means to better understand
the intimacies
of slavery and capitalism and the
importance
of slavery's transformation under racial
settler colonialism not just to
modern capital capitalism's conditions
of possibility
but also to its core technologies of
violence is both material
and social that shape our worlds
to this day thank you
thank you so much this is where there
would be thunderous applause
and we just are imagining it
in this moment thank you for a great
and eye-opening presentation we're going
to
open the floor to questions and i'm
going to ask folks to put their
questions in the chat i especially
invite students from the seminar
to pose questions maybe i'll start with
one that's okay if you're ready
yeah yeah um so
you know i find it totally
convincing and i wonder what other steps
we could take in thinking about this
um system
the system before the system the first
system the model prototype system
and so one thing that happens in
the wage labor system that mark spends a
long time talking about in capital is
the pressure to increase
productivity and to expand the system
and some of that has to do with
encountering limits
to the number of wage laborers that you
can get
but there seems to be a kind of motor of
growth in it
and i wonder if you see anything like
that in the slave capital system that
preceded it that you've been describing
growth how technology fits is there any
pressure to
make the slave trade
obsolete to diminish it in those ways to
help the growth of surplus
value or is growth not that big of a
factor oh i would say growth is a huge
factor
and i think you know part of i think
what happens is that we
we tend to um view these things
teleologically
so you know again of course
wage labor under industrialization
innovate something even
further but if we're looking at the
slave system on its own
terms instead of looking at it you know
already comparing it to what
is going to happen 100 years later
it's an inefficient system comparative
compared to what's going to develop
but it's a system in which people are
desperately trying to innovate
right and so you know some of the
studies for instance of plantation
slavery and the sugar colonies in the
caribbean has shown that
there's an increase in productivity that
can only be explained
by you know the further ramping up of
slave labor
and i think part of what
we're i'm trying to do here and one of
the things i think we struggle with
is you know the only measure we have in
many ways
of the immensity of that system is the
the quantitative history you know the
numbers and
it's just so easy to let 12 and a half
million become an abstraction
you know um it's so hard for us to
really visualize
how much that is the social reproduction
of slavery you know th this this
this maxim of using the slave laborer up
knowing that you can replace them that
it is more efficient
so again this idea that slavery can't
work
it shouldn't work but it did
right and so that's i think what we have
to reckon with is just
how much they were able and willing to
make it work and that they did so
through a bureaucratic means of
management you know i think part of what
marx is always trying to do
is to make this primitive accumulation
because it's happening
you know um extrajudicially you know and
outside the state and it's this kind of
domain of the wild and the prodigal
and and no it's the state you know
um and the archive
the colonial archive the colonial state
archive that that documents it
is going to make its way to the british
library if he were researching capital
um probably would have needed to be you
know maybe 50 years later
instead of pouring over you know the
blue books he could have poured over
um you know the royal african company's
papers
thanks guess that would would have
changed a lot
one hopes and okay
i'm not seeing questions in the chat so
much so if you want to raise some issues
or make some comments please feel free
to do it
i can of course keep asking
we're gonna get looking at some of the
comments
yeah i think what happens sometimes with
a such
an opening of a whole new world is that
you can't ask the usual
you know marx people like to debate the
finest technical points
it's very rarely interesting but
[Music]
this is a whole new issue
from the mark side obviously question
could you say a little more about the
role of bureaucratic management it
sounds like
as a way that the state managed slavery
as labor it is maybe parallel or
precursor to the juridical equality that
as you point out
marx emphasized
um i'm not sure what more to say but i
guess but i'll just say that
what i'm trying to emphasize again is
that it seems to me part of what marx
wants to do is to imagine the slave
system
and the violences of colonialism
generally
as as not really being um
the arm of the state right um especially
in the
in the early modern period
right and so i think that
part of what strikes what struck me even
as a researcher when i started studying
the slave trade again was just to
realize just
how bureaucratic
and rationalized it was and i think when
we try
to make sense of certain kinds of
violence
as again being
outside the domain of the bureaucratic
state you know this kind of
wild
space that's that's that's not managed
um i think that's a way that we try to
rationalize it and i think what we have
to reckon with again
is the kinds of
violence that the state was quite happy
and
and dependent upon upon managing in a
very rationalizing way
we have another question um from
sarah maria sorrentino maybe we'll open
up
sarah maria's mike and and they can ask
the question themselves
hi hi thanks for the talk i was
wondering if you could say a little bit
more
about how it would be possible to
to understand or think slavery on its
own terms
like do you think that there are
particular ways in which we understand
the critique of political economy and
understand capitalism is it totality and
understand
materialism is a kind of form of
metaphysics that might
preclude us from understanding slavery
on its own terms
like what what kind of conceptual and
political tools might we
might we need in order to begin that
endeavor
i guess i don't have a really uh
deeply formulated answer to that
question i mean i think
and i'm being told that my internet
connection is unstable can you guys hear
me
forgetting you pretty clearly yep i i
think
the way to to see it on its own terms
is simply to
to just you know use the archival
material that we have
and be critically reflective such that
we're not
projecting teleologically
you know other formations onto the slave
system i don't know if that makes sense
but
i don't have a really
sophisticated way to just to say what i
mean by that i don't think
yeah i get i mean this is something that
i i study in research and so if
if part of like our understanding of
ideology or the way that capitalism
impacts
our consciousness is the to make it so
that we see
certain versions of freedom
this problematic that you've posed um
in terms of ways that marx was unable to
think capitalism
has has impacted our critical
consciousness
whether whether we like can just
approach the archive
as such or or whether there's a
particular way in which the framing of
capitalism as the problem has actually
inhibited our critical capacity for
or reflection well i think
that it's as i'm listening to your
question i'm also reminded that um
you know the the the series here is
um the value of capital
uh and i hope my you know kind of taking
marks
to task doesn't imply that i don't value
capital because
i value it enormously and i think one of
the things
that marx's critique of political
economy does
is help us to
take apart the otherwise very very
opaque
liberal philosophical assumptions that
guide
so much of western
analysis and so i think
that's a big part of i think what we
need to do in order to
to sort of undo some of the assumptions
that guide how we understand these
systems i mean for instance
one of the reasons marx's critique is so
compelling to me
and one i want to try to use to
understand colonial slavery is because a
lot of the mainstream historiography
is very happy to figure the atlantic
slavery system as nothing more or less
than the continuation
of late medieval systems you know
already in existence and so there's a
failure to really reckon with the way
that colonial slavery
was a revolutionary transformation
of late medieval and earlier systems
and i think marks this analysis can help
us do that
with some corrections for some of the
things that the blinders
that marx had we have some other
questions
i want to just throw one in in the
middle because you're on the topic
that is that i see that you want to
illuminate this
other really other system complete in
itself without comparing it constantly
to capital
but it does seem since it's the the
first innovation or it's going on
simultaneously with things that are
going on in europe
um in other realms where you see
the influences going there
um from this this system of bookkeeping
this
is this idea of surplus value um
and how it might have even if it's
speculative i'm curious
influenced this other invention
europe yeah and i'm curious too i mean i
think that's what we all need to be
trying to figure out and i think it's
not going to be something that we're
going to figure out necessarily
through the mode of
you know empirical research i mean i i
wonder what are
the you know the structures of feeling
what
what are the things that are embedded in
a culture
um and again that's where i think it
really matters to realize that
you know three centuries of realizing
the capacity
to produce surplus labor through
the alienation of labor power
how does that not
set the stage for
the subsequent revolutionary shift that
marx is so keen to track and again
you know part of what i want to make
clear and i probably didn't in the talk
is that
i'm actually less frustrated that marx
didn't do the things
he could and should have done because i
don't think it's really that mysterious
that that marx
wanted to sort of confine things the way
that he did i mean he had some very real
goals he really was
trying to help stoke the revolutionary
shift
in his 19th century moment so it's less
really that i'm frustrated with marx
but that i'm frustrated with marxism
right
for not going ahead and asking the
questions
that marx didn't ask because what's so
interesting is how much he did but he
didn't and that's why i really like
um you know lisa's way of of showing us
how
he sees but doesn't see um so much
of the analysis that i'm looking for is
there in capital you always think he's
right about to just
really go there so again he knows
on some level he does know
i think i'm with you
all right let's go to some more
questions in the chat if you don't mind
i will
um open ask to open the mic
of flory siri is a short but interesting
question
we will say yours
sure thank you um i i you know
that there are million things wrong with
slavery obviously but it seems
could could you speak about how it
really um
in my estimation interfered with any
kind of innovation
uh in agriculture
i'm sorry can you say that again um can
you
opine a bit about how
slavery interfered with innovation
in agriculture
i mean i'm not sure i would say that it
did
plantation managers were
always trying to figure out new ways to
make
the system more productive experimenting
with different
cultigens you know of whatever the the
crop was that they were
making their enslaved workers produce
was there not um because there was such
a reliance on this free
abuse of labor uh did that not impede
the idea of
thinking more creatively about systems
to produce in a way that wouldn't be so
harmful
um
i don't you know i mean i think it's
relative
i you know i guess what i'm hesitating
because
they're they're such a powerful sense
and you get this in marks he
i mean he has a whole passage about this
somewhere in capital i'm forgetting
exactly where
you know this notion again this was the
such a powerful idea in the 19th century
that slavery was inefficient
again of course comparatively speaking
it was but again i don't know that it's
helpful
to evaluate
the thinking of plantation owners
relative to what was going to come
with the kinds of innovations about
around productivity that
shaped industrial capitalism and i think
if you were to ask the planters
they understood themselves to be people
who were interested
in in doing things better i mean there
was a whole genre of you know plantation
management literature that was about
this very thing
within the limits of what was available
in terms of scientific thought in terms
of
technology in the 16th 17th and 18th
centuries
particularly the the 18th century and
into the early 19th century
one thing i was taking from your talk
and your argument is that the
strategies of management in the slave
trade system itself were innovations
these are technologies technologies of
control of movement
of yeah human beings of conversion of
human beings into commodities
which you explain so eloquently happened
acro going across the atlantic those are
technologies even if they're not
machines yeah i mean things like the
dulban act
you know the the dolby act in 1788 where
they said well you know what
yeah we we've decided that overcrowding
is is causing uh more
deaths in the middle passage so here's
how we're going to manage it you know
we're going
you know we're going to calculate just
how much
you know square footage per body
um makes death acceptable
you know it gives us a quotient of
mortality
that is acceptable that that was
late 18th century innovation
and it's a beautiful parallel i hate to
keep saying this
not beautiful but it is a parallel to
what mark says about
wage labor which is it's this peculiar
commodity
that gets shaped and pushed around the
technologies of life
are intimately bound up with the
production of surplus value
yeah um can we go i'm going to pick and
choose a little bit because some of them
are not
some of the questions are not exactly on
topic but there is a question of the
relationship of this system to
systems of indigenous enslaved labor so
let's
ask sebastian lopez to ask
their question
thanking audrey for finding these names
in the list and
unmuting them and this total mess
that we're living in thank you audrey
hi um thank you for that
for the talk it's so generative and and
i feel like there's
many different theoretical points that
uh
i think open up a perspective on how
many different formations were happening
constantly
in what we call capital at the moment
and so i was wondering
um even though you weren't talking about
this but
in gesturing to the multiplicity of
formations at this moment
if you could elaborate a little on how
you see
the relation between uh
atlantic slave labor um and for example
the different forms of um slave labor
that were happening
in for indigenous peoples in the
americas and i'm thinking
here for example of there's this
particular narrative that the encomienda
was abolished and then kind of like
indigenous labor disappeared
but then that transmuted into different
forms of
of for slavery and so i'm thinking of
like uh
roxiones apollos de indios
uh hacienda and stuff like that and so
the question is coming out of like um
how do we understand land dispossession
uh in slave labor and also the
different forms in which indigenous
lands labor
has well changed and how yeah kind of
like
something like that yeah yeah no that's
a great question thank you
um well i was one of the reasons i
occasionally uh on purpose
and the talk referred not just to
colonialism
generally but more specifically to
racial settler colonialism was in fact
to try
to signify um how much
the the system that that that we're
referring to
really really really should be
understood has to be understood
as a system that used as i always put it
slavery and indigenous dispossession as
twin tools
of colonizing and that's something that
i'd say is a leading edge of
of new work i think it's a wonderful
turn that's happening in scholarship
on the early americas to recognize
the entwined stories
of african and indigenous slavery
and of indigenous territorial
dispossession
and colonizing and slavery
that accompanies that colonizing so
we know so much more now because of the
research that's
that's starting to turn into
publications in the past 10 years or so
about how prolific
indigenous slavery was um and how much
even as in some parts of the americas
indigenous slavery gave way to other
systems of exploitation like encomiendo
reportimiento that they are still
systems that completely disrupt
indigenous systems
of rule of dominion of sovereignty
um and and they're of a peace with
african slavery there
peace alongside african slavery with
with
what colonizing um entailed
i hope that answers the question a
little bit
okay let's go to some more questions if
if everyone has energy we're all low
energy because it's been such an
exhausting 24 hours
so we'll just admit that and but we're
going to keep going because this is
this is of lasting importance
there's some technical questions about
some marxian categories
yeah well what i would say to that and
thank you for that question what i would
say to that is
is that that is why i tried to make it
clear that
that i'm certainly not trying to
collapse
um the distinction between the two labor
forms
um because they were different and
but i am insisting that that that
the the initial one uh involving
colonial slavery
needs to be more squarely centered
in the story of capital um than marx
is able or willing to do
and on the question of social
reproduction again that's where
the need to to to
really come to grips
with the scale of the slave trade comes
into play because that was
the system's means of social
reproduction
right that's what i was thinking that
that's
that's how it is that you
you know and and the only way we have to
really take the measure of it is you
know demographic
scholarship and research that i mean i
try to teach this stuff and my students
eyes just glaze over because it's dry
stuff
but it's the demographic data is the
reflection
of you know what does it mean to have
populations that cannot reproduce
themselves biologically
and so every time a slave ship comes
back you know that's why
it's so compelling to me to get this
planter carrie hellyer just say you know
i'm gonna make these slaves buy more
slaves i mean it's
that is the logic that's the system
i'm going to skip a little bit down to
some questions that are
more on topic i'm not ignoring the
people with broader questions but i want
to
focus around the talk at least first
that's okay
i'm going to read the question for berta
morata whose microphone is
out question is how would you articulate
the relation between the appropriation
of slave labor
and the appropriation of nature ecology
appropriation of what
nature which uh berta is calling
ecological surplus in the long
durati
alienation of labor alienation of nature
how would i
characterize the relationship between
the two
yeah i'm not sure what the question is
getting at but let's speculate
hmm well um
it's not a question i have given a lot
of thought to
um i guess thinking off the top of my
head
i would say that were i
to pursue it um
i think it would lead me again to
taking more seriously
than i think we have in historical
scholarship
what are the logics of of colonizing
you know what are the what are the costs
what are the technologies of
dispossession
um what are the environmental
consequences
of plantation labor and there are you
know their scholarship that that is
beginning to pursue this i'm not caught
up on it
to be blunt um but i think i i think
there's a literature emerging
that you know that that correlates to
the question
why don't we go on it's a good question
it's good it's a good
avenue to pursue
next question on the list is from
deontay harris
can we unmute de ante this is a question
kind of write solidly in your real house
yes i am here thank you so much dr
smallwood for this talk i hope that
you're able to hear me okay
yes um the question um i had was
thinking about processes of
commodification and
also thinking about labor power and
wanting to have more discussion about
the differences between
commodification of things versus the
commodification of human beings
right um and also how then to analyze
these relationally together to
understand
that there were multiple processes
happening at the same time which makes
this particular system so
interesting unique and horrifying at the
same time
so if you could speak a bit too you know
about this process of commodifying human
beings in this atlantic system and how
then their combined labor powers then to
i guess used to uh you know generate or
create
you know more commodities for the
international uh market
yeah um the commodification of people
is that that's where my research
took off um and in the book that i wrote
on the slave trade and i
it was when i you know when i went into
the archives of the slave trade i would
ask myself
what have i learned that i didn't
already know
about the slave trade and how it worked
and
that literally was my method um and it's
it's what
led to the the structure of the book
which
became a story organized around
commodification as how
people became slaves and how the system
achieved
the efficiency that it did achieve
within the context of the 17th and 18th
centuries
it was an efficient system i would say
again that
that's that's how it did what it
shouldn't have been able to do
which was to displace so many
millions of people and so
you know i think in that sense the
commodification of people
really reflected a logic that was
that became very comfortable and this is
how it becomes
um you know and i'm thinking of cedric
robinson's work here this is how it
becomes
a differentiating logic right a logic
that
is without necessarily even yet
producing what we would recognize as
obvious discourses of race but producing
certainly
a logic of some humans
being more readily
and more more appropriately treated
as though they are things
than others and so it's
it's not particularly different than the
commodification
of things except
the the oddity the peculiarity
to return to the marxian formulation
of the human as a commodity is that it's
a perishable commodity
right and there are some things that
that share that that quality
but that is also part of what becomes so
profoundly inhumane
in the violence of of colonial slavery
is the the kinds of
choices and the kinds of violence
and destruction
that has to be naturalized and
normalized
in order to produce people
as though they are things
so to reduce for instance
people to one of
four demographic categories of either
being a man or a woman or a boy or a
girl that kind of evacuation
of all qualities of personhood
right in order to reduce
a crowd of people to
a slave cargo so that a slave ship
can continue its scheduled movement
in transatlantic circuits
i hope that begins to answer the
question absolutely thank you so very
much
thanks i want to move to another
question by
my colleague lisa lowe who's been
invoked a couple times tonight
we'll give her the microphone audrey
would you unmute
mr lowe thank you thank you for
your beautiful talk um i sense that your
critique of marx
has much greater stakes than simply
correcting his analysis
of um capitalism in an empirical sense
though i'm persuaded that his reduction
of slavery as primitive accumulation
does obscure the scale and periodization
and the nature of violence and
the violability of this enslaved body
and
the forms of extraction and so forth but
i wanted to ask you what you think if
you think there's a material or
political effect or
afterlife of this mistaken reduction
um the missing of slavery as labor
or surplus value circulating within a
global
labor market and what the consequences
of periodizing
slavery as primitive accumulation or
prior to capitalism might be
what does that say about
what we can't see about the continuation
of primitive accumulation
as co-evil or continuous with
yeah yeah thank you for that question
lisa
well i think for me the stakes are that
and i guess i was trying to gesture at
this a little bit in the very
uh the last few sentences of the talk
you know i think if if we were
to consider that
colonial slavery is squarely within
the ambit of the history of capital c
capitalism it would mean not only
a rethinking of the relationship of
slavery to industrial capitalization but
it would entail a rethinking of
slavery's relationship to our present i
mean i i think it would allow us to
understand
capitalism today as the continued
playing out
of colonial slavery it would allow us to
see ourselves as part of
a genealogy that begins with slavery it
would make slavery
part of our genealogy and i think that
that that has
profound um productive implications
thank you
okay yes i was getting on a sub channel
text from a graduate student which is
something i wanted to add to
which is that it really makes the whole
metaphoric
in capital stand out this is from a
graduate student
she sent this privately but i'm going to
out her vanessa gubbins
every time mark says it's like slaves
wage labor is slavery it's all there
it's right on the surface of the text
yeah it's haunted by slavery it's really
haunted by slavery
it's hard to imagine he's thinking of
rome in those instances
well thank you very much for this um
kind presence a brilliant opening up of
the text
a um a stand on a day that's really
very difficult for everyone we really
appreciate your coming and
we hope that people take up this
challenge you've given to
fill in the gaps and make the
connections and give us a better picture
of our genealogy so thank you so much
thank you very much for having me
thank you this is another moment a big
applause this would sound very loud
thank you thanks